john eu literalmente causou na rua
lembra aquelas propagandas onde a mulher
vai passando e todos os olhares se
voltam para ela então essa sou eu na rua
desde sempre
logo percebi que não era por causa dos
meus lindos olhos verdes mas sim por
causa do meu gracinho aliás gente deixa
apresentar o meu brasil pra vocês
não precisa ter medo ele não morde ele é
um fofo e da personalidade ótima rio
bracinho nós nascemos juntos e eu não
sei se alguém que tem um irmão gêmeo mas
quando a gente nasce com alguém é uma
coisa muito louca porque uma pessoa
sempre se destacou mais e essa pessoa
foi o bracinho ele sempre chamou mais
atenção do que eu e eu queria ser a
mariana mas eu nunca fui só mariana eu
sempre fui a mariana do bracinho e e por
conta disso a gente teve uma relação
muito complicada eu acabava que eu
tentava escondê lo de todas as formas
possíveis
então eu fiz lá uns 11 anos cansada de
receber tanto olhar na rua eu decidi que
eu ia esconder ele então toda vez que eu
colocava uma roupinha de manga cumprida
ninguém percebia que eu não tinha um
braço eu passava por aí desapercebido eu
acho isso ótimo
só não era tão legal quando estava a 40
graus na fora eu estava de casaco
percebendo que eu não podia ficar
escondendo isso o tempo todo eu resolvi
partir para outro lado então eu comecei
a querer uma prótese
eu lembro quantos anos eu tinha mas
muitas pessoas desde pequena perguntavam
para minha mãe quando ela ia me dar uma
prótese e minha mãe sempre me falou que
era só quando eu tivesse totalmente
desenvolvida porque senão ia ficar
trocando de próprio tempo todo porque
não sei se vocês sabem a prótese é feita
do tamanho certinho do seu braço também
da sua mão etc
e aí quando eu fiz 16 anos eu falei pra
minha mãe tô desenvolvida academia
prótese e aí ela me deu até o próprio
anzhi quando a prótese chegou
gente eu odiei a prótese
parecia que alguém tinha pegado um braço
de um manequim com uma cor completamente
mais escura que a minha e me dava de
presente falando toma e seu braço e eu
não queria isso eu queria ter dois
braços
eu queria passar despercebida na rua e
isso foi na época que eu entrei na
faculdade então quando eu entrei na
faculdade
na primeira festinha eu estava lá é de
boa dançando descontraída com meu novo
braço até que ele cai no chão e faz um
barulho absurdo e gente eu passei tanta
vergonha tanta vergonha com essa prótese
que eu comecei a perceber que eu ia ter
que mudar alguma coisa em mim porque
essa prótese não foi a solução dos meus
problemas eu colocava culpa dos meus
problemas no bracinho e quanto mais eu
diminuí a ele mas eu escondia mas eu
abafava mas a minha autoestima carrinha
eu não conseguia me desvincular dele ele
estava lá desde a primeira vez que eu
tenho um laço no sapato
até meu primeiro beijo ele sempre esteve
comigo e hoje em dia eu percebo que não
sou só eu que sofri com padrões
estéticos e sofro
hoje em dia eu percebo que pessoas sem
deficiência sofrem pelo corpo que elas
têm e não conseguem olhar com carinho
para si próprio não consegue perceber
que esse é o corpo que a gente tem
e a gente está sempre querendo uma coisa
mais emagrecer peito bunda músculos e
gente
sinceramente eu nunca ia conseguir ter
um braço
então eu tive que olhar pra mim e
perceber que eu nunca ia ter um braço e
eu lembrou que isso foi muito difícil
pra mim porque eu era a única pessoa da
minha turma que não tinha um braço
eu era a única pessoa que não tinha um
braço que eu conhecia eu não via ninguém
na tv eu não via ninguém no teatro não
vê ninguém no filme até que eu assisti é
duas mãos de tesoura e eu lembro que eu
amei o filme porque pela primeira vez na
vida um protagonista não tinha mãos e
gente eu me identifiquei tanto com a 2
com a história dele eu adorava ver ele
cortando arbustos e cara eu acho que nem
nos sonhos mais profundos do tim burton
uma mina lá de florianópolis em um braço
e identificar tanto com é dois irmãos
detidos
é um filme de terror trash am
eu vivi a minha vida toda à espera de
representatividade e ela não chegava
e quando a internet chegou eu acho que
ninguém contava com a força dela pra dá
voz a opressões estruturais da sociedade
com a internet as minorias viraram
multidões e eu via as pessoas falando
sobre gênero sobre cor sobre raça eu não
via as pessoas falando sobre deficiência
a deficiência
ela é uma minoria dentro da própria
minoria porque a gente é esquecido a
gente é escondido a gente não é lembrado
e quando você vai falar sobre
deficiência você traz um especialista
você traz um médico você traz um
psicólogo você não traz uma pessoa com
deficiência e isso me incomodava muito
então eu eo brasil tivemos uma idéia
genial de criar um canal no youtube para
falar sobre isso e desde então eu venho
representando milhares de pessoas com
deficiência por esse brasil e muitas
delas nem têm a mesma eficiência que eu
mas ela se vem na minha fala elas se
sentem incluídos pelas coisas que eu
passo pelo meu dia a dia ea
representatividade gente ela tem uma
força muito grande é tem algumas pessoas
que assistem ao canal que são meus
gêmeos de bracinho que são as pessoas
que eu chamo que tem a mesma eficiência
que eu e essas pessoas elas sempre vêm
me contar como elas nunca tinham
conhecido ninguém igual a elas
e hoje em dia eu conheço milhares de
pessoas que não têm o mesmo prazo que eu
percebo que nem é tão diferente assim
e esses dias recebi uma mensagem de uma
mãe que tem um filho gêmeo de bracinho e
eles me falaram que ela me falou que
assim ela queria whatsapp porque ela
queria que eu fizesse tipo uma chamada
de vod vídeo com o filho dela porque ele
desde que me viu na tv no programa de
tevê perguntava todos os dias pra ela
quando o que a moça do brasil e está na
tevê de novo porque ele se viu
representado por mim ele viu que ele
pertence aquilo e é uma coisa que ele
nunca teve antes que eu nunca tive antes
então é por mais que a gente aceite as
nossas diferenças
sempre que a gente tem que assumir elas
tipo tirar do armário sabe sair do
armário e falar olha eu sou essa pessoa
eu tenho isso eu vivo com isso mas isso
não me defini
eu acreditava pelos pelas diversas
ligações que já tive na vida de a isso
não vai dar pra você fazer isso não
mariana não precisa lavar louça e
querida fica tranquila vários horários
de pena me traziam uma idéia de que a
deficiência era uma coisa ruim
era uma coisa que me limitava era uma
coisa que me fazia menor que os outros
até que eu percebi que nenhum e quando
eu percebi isso eu disse eu preciso
falar isso para outras pessoas
então às vezes recebo mensagens de
pessoas sem deficiência que me dizem que
elas estão muito agradecidos por eu
estar ali mostrando como que eu vivo com
a minha deficiência e continua sendo uma
pessoa forte com personalidade que me
ama e isso é muito louco e é
revolucionário porque as pessoas não
esperem que você ame você mesmo vai
contra tudo o que nos é imposto você se
amar de verdade principalmente se você
tiver uma deficiência isso choca
como assim ela é feliz e eu não então o
que eu quero dizer para vocês hoje é que
eu comecei o canal com o impulso eu
comecei o canal porque eu não me via
representada na cultura então se você
não se vê representado nos filmes nas
séries nos livros começa a falar sobre
isso assuma o protagonismo da sua vida e
lute pelas suas próprias lutas não
espere pelos outros
a gente precisa de você a gente precisa
ver o mundo pelos seus olhos
obrigada
[Aplausos]